the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
I also had a couple of students asking
me about what do you do after this class
if you want to take more classes and
games if you want to take more classes
in game design if you're thinking about
the the spring semester I just wanted to
throw some course numbers up here so
there's CMS 301 is introduction to game
design methods if you're interested in
design research if you're interested in
design methods and you happen to also be
interested in games but you're likely
going to be doing things in design
elsewhere so that might be application
design toy design anything physical
anything game like whatever the methods
are going to teach them there are going
to be useful for all those things but
the class is focused on as using game
design as a way to talk about design
methods so CMS 301 CMS 608 the class
Philip teaches and I co-teach with them
on game design so if you want to know
more about how games are designed some
topics we talk about are things like
game balance seems tuning the projects
are all board games and card games so
the entire class is done with analog
game design so we can actually get more
more detail into how rules work how
rules mix together we play a bunch of
board games we analyze them and then we
make board games it's very similarly
structured in this class it's team-based
you'll do for game design projects in
that class there is CMS 610 that is
media industries and systems the art
science and business of games as topic
Chris Weaver from Bethesda Softworks he
worked on the Elder Scrolls series for a
while his class is focused on the
business and publish your side of the
equation of game development so if
you're thinking about doing this as a
professional career at some point you're
likely gonna have to deal with
publishers either you're going to be
working for one you're the studio will
be working for one or you will be
pitching one to one yourself so the big
focus of that class is the pitch how do
you pitch your ideas to another group
and it's also focused on the demo so if
anybody's heard of the term e3 demo
basically how to make your game look
good even though it doesn't work
hopefully the game works at the end but
it's really focused on what do you need
in your game in order to communicate
that game to another person in order to
fit to order to provide funding for your
game so that's CMS 610 really great
course he has a lot of really good war
stories from what the game development
process was like from the 80s on up and
then lastly see ms 617 Sarah and I teach
that course it's called advanced game
studio it's basically an independent
study but with teams to make games you
spend the entire semester making a
single game Sarah and I act kind of as
your publisher kind of as your mom and
dad kind of as your mentor basically we
are there to help you make your game to
help your game from start to finish on
behalf something that you can you could
either submit to a festival you could
show to another person put in a
portfolio before you start this class
you should be in a team already so we'll
be sending emails out out about this we
try to do a few events in January for
networking and for people to meet each
other to form teams but you can form
teams with people you've met in this
class in other classes I have a feeling
that people who took this class last
year are going to be looking for teams
for this year so there'll be there'll be
some emails going out around December
and January and hopefully a one or two
events going on at the lab in January
about that um yeah and then if anybody
has any questions about if you want a
minor in in games I'm at MIT if you want
to do a concentration in games at MIT
you can do that through comparative
Media Studies and writing you can talk
to me about that after class you can
also go to the CMS w website and talk to
Rebecca Shepherdson about that about
what the requirements are for that but
say full its comparative Media Studies
it's multiple media but you can also
gains is one of those media that you can
focus on and concentrate in okay so that
is the advertisement part of this class
so today we're going to finish up team
formation we're going to i'm going to
introduce the project for deadlines
which i briefly mentioned last week and
then we're going to start project for
today you've got a lot of time today to
do brainstorming and to do prototyping
in your team's recommend we're
recommending that if you're gonna have
you're going to have eight person teams
breaking up into smaller groups to do
some initial prototyping you want
basically think of this as prototyping
as a means of brainstorming to come up
with lots of different kinds of
mechanics actually try those mechanics
out and play with them a little bit
before you before you decide on one
we're giving you a lot of time to do
this this week because you want we want
to you to have something playable by
next Monday that's that four teams we've
got it sounds to me like we had five
topics that were interesting to folks
where does anybody still interested in
the malaria topic okay na malaria why do
you let me come up here and talk to you
what was it Ebola Ebola yeah so nobody
was interesting that all right so um
I've got early warning leading to early
action for heat waves color prevention
and hygiene forecast based funding snap
and adapting to climate change even
though we've got five topics that does
not mean we need to have one team per
topic some of these some teams we can
have multiple teams doing welcome the
same topic and that's okay so raise your
hand if you don't think you're on a team
right now okay it's a good portion of
you so what we're going to do is just
like last time we're going to break up
into groups based in the room if you're
interested in the topic go to that group
talk with those folks if you are in that
group and you signed off you said that
you are definitely on this team um
through the mailing list identify
yourself to the group as yes I signed up
for this on the mailing list this is
what the team is so far here that people
on this team right now and actually to
help that through what I'm going to do
is put these on the board they'd have
people who signed up for that team come
down first and then everyone else come
down so over here let's do
he weighs over here let's do cholera
snap climate change and forecast base
funding so if you are already on one of
these teams and you said this is the
team I want to be on go to that go to
that area right now yeah whatever that's
guy all right so heat waves one two
three four five cholera one two three
four five color six cholera seven are
you standing up are you anybody here on
snap one two three four five six seven
cool come on if you're on snap come on
down with the rest of the group adapting
the climate change if you're on the team
if you think you're on that team okay
and then forecast based funding if you
think you're on that team 12 so far okay
all right um so if we're going to one
two three four five six was only six
okay so um move to whatever team that
you're interested in right now talk with
some folks talk about if you're on the
team already talked about some of the
things that even talk that you talked
about last week brainstorming wives if
you want to be on that team talk with
the members and ask if you can be on
that team basically I'm going to check
in any o arm in 10 minutes to see what
we look what it looks like
also wins
Oh
right after this amount of discussion
how many people are still undecided
about what team they want to be on a
kind of a decided anybody else kind of
undecided all right so if you are one
hundred percent decided put your name on
your post it put it up on one of these
things do it really really quick come up
put it up sit back down please alright
so the dangers of having more than than
10 people yeah so I in fact just in fact
that there is already dangers of having
eight people or more but this class was
actually intended for you to actually
feel that pressure right we've got a
person team you're going to have
communication problems of the wazoo that
tables might be careful um yeah your
laptop's on it the the and once you get
to a 10-person team what we've seen from
previous years is that 10 people teens
don't act 10 people and larger teams
don't actually outperform six person
teams they actually get about the same
amount done or sometimes less because
the communication overhead actually
breaks down further you might get a lot
of content done and it turns out to be
very uneven in quality because you're
multiple people doing content now you
could succeed in breaking your team up
into little subgroups and be able to
organize yourselves that way but we've
never seen it done successfully in this
class with students you know with your
level of experience so what we won't
recommend is that for a team well if
you've got something like 12 people in
all 13 people now in a pile 13 yeah you
will probably get more done by splitting
into two groups if you are deliberately
brainstorming in order to take advantage
of 30 people that of course they are
going to come up with a game that can
only be executed by a very large number
of people well we're just saying is that
those games have traditionally not done
very very well in in our class they may
be functional they
may actually deliver on the thing that
you intended to make but we've seen six
person teams too much more partly
because the iterator whole lot faster
and they may have smaller ideas but the
ideas end up being a whole lot more
polished so that's our advice to you it
is I if they really want to do thirteen
percent team are we going to let them um
wow yeah judgment against our better
judgment we might but we're going to
really what we're going to ask I think
today is to break up into small into two
smaller teams for brainstorming we
actually we want all the big all the big
teams to even break up into smaller
teams anyway to do some brainstorming
and to do some prototyping once you have
all that figured out in class today by
the end of class today you can decide
how big you want the team to really be
they were the one issue but we have
those we've got some people who are not
in class today who will be coming in the
class about the three that we talked
about there might be one or two more if
there are any other people like that
they will be automatically put on the
smallest of these teams so I'd rather
them turn into a six person in cholera
turn 27 rather than an eighth turned in
a night because he's a person teams are
actually just good enough yeah the a
person teams are just about the size
that we were hoping for six person teams
actually to be perfectly honest I think
the sixth person teams have an advantage
but you know that's that's just numbers
that has that just hard that was
breakdown yeah the when we have seen a
10-person team actually work what really
happened was it was ten people eight of
them worked on the game to have worked
on the networking component the
networking component did not work yet
the game was still as feature complete
as it could be without networking it
could it could work without the
networking that's not what we're looking
for we want the the game that you are
submitting the game that you're creating
the design document that you're
submitting to us on wednesday and the
game that you're play testing on monday
to be the actual game all those features
that you're saying are going to be in
that game to be the actual game that you
submit at the end of the semester so
don't think of it as well if two people
flake then it's back up not do people if
two people flake if you're too big and
you've got to people who don't know
what's going on and they caused some
issues
it's is going to be a disaster for the
entire team did anybody in previous so
this year all of the projects to and
private three teams were actually bigger
than we've done them in LA in previous
years previous years we were there about
four people maybe five tops I me how do
you do six and seven I think right did
anybody feel like with seven people they
got a communication method that worked
really well like already like okay I see
what what was that what was the method
yeah I mean it's the sort of thing they
could what whatever method you use will
definitely improve with practice right
so so so if you got something that sort
of worked well something to try again
but the fact that most people didn't you
know gives us and it should already give
you some warning of what a large team is
going to feel like it's going to be
tough for the structure of the class on
Wednesday we're going to be talking
about more of the requirements the
aesthetic requirements for project floor
we talking a little bit well we have
another basically another design
discussion next wednesday on monday
we're having a short design discussion
about educational games and then we'll
have a one of our first discussions
trying to talk about some of the person
the person person issues we see in
making games but in this case it's team
dynamics and how to identify team
dynamics I'll have a couple more talks
like that to kind of help you get used
to running in a bigger team but between
now and next monday we're hoping in
class to give you a plenty of time to
actually work on some of the send one of
the biggest issues with working in a big
team is just figuring out what is what
is that core thing that you're actually
making what's the thing you're trying to
communicate to each other we've talked
to talked about how you can use the
division document for that and I you can
use the prototyping the actual prototype
you make for that but often it is just
having everybody in the same room at the
same time talking and just working
together so we're trying to give you as
much time as you can in class because
you know hard enough to get six people
outside of class to me to let let let
alone a a person team right so we're
going to give you more time inc
to meet up with with each other that
does not mean that you should be
spending all your time and class
planning on getting your face to face
coding done that's actually a waste of
time because you could be talking to
each other you can do that but things
like code reviews code reviews stand-up
meetings on things like that okay all
right so we're going to put this on hold
for a second I'm going to go over the
very quickly the deadlines and then
we're going to take a break and come
back so if this will move forward all
right so why did I react so strongly
about the animal crossing all these
sorts of minigames because what we're
asking you to do whoa don't do that all
right so what we're asking to do is
create a small fully functional polished
browser game one of those mini games
would count as a small fully functional
well-polished browser game we're asking
you to use the design iteration
techniques you've used in the past what
does that mean we're actually talking
about the same design scope as the
previous two projects is just you spent
more time on it to actually get it
working exactly the way you'd want it to
work if you had maybe slightly larger so
if your previous two projects had maybe
one core mechanic and one supplementary
there might be two supplementary
mechanics to that core but that's about
it if you've got a game that has an
overworld then the overworld should be
the bulk of your game if you're spinning
if the minigames that you decided to
make are the same size is that overworld
in scope that's already way too over
scoped that make sense it's an eight
week project we're giving you you've got
about two weeks to concept and prototype
multiple game like multiple game
experiences so we're asking for today
and tomorrow on Wednesday is you're not
just prototyping one game you're
prototyping lots and lots of different
little games looking at all those games
you actually have time to spend you're
gonna have time to spend on multiple
different prototypes rather than just a
single prototype that you iterate on so
we're asking is if you got an eight
person team
break yourself into two groups of four
four groups of to create some really
small bord gáis me looking things some
very small interactions maybe they're
playable maybe there's something you
just described but really go big blue
sky and try to think of all the
different things that can happen with
with these topics that you're dealing
with are very large and we make sure
that your design is grounded very very
well granted in the sources that we've
been given by the client there's gonna
be multiple times when they'll be here
to see your games and talk about your
games they'll be on your email so that
you can ask some questions about that as
well so design constraints use all the
mechanics that we've been practicing in
class on with your previous projects not
all not all the mechanics simultaneously
use any of those make any of those
mechanics so it could have trade-offs it
could have randomest it is not required
to have both it's required to have
whatever it takes for the project that
you're for the topic that you're working
on whatever makes sense for the topic
that you're working on those top to tend
to be in the realm of what those topics
kind of lean themselves towards but if
you find something else and you want to
use that something else great spend some
time really working on it I spent a
couple weeks working on it before you
make a full commitment so your target
audience since each of those topics has
on their own target audiences which they
talked about the top three are the ones
to really focus on on depending on your
topic so Red Cross staff and volunteers
so people who are knowledgeable and
motivated about the topic already who
just need a little bit extra information
community organizers arm and then youth
people who are motivated but maybe not
knowledgeable about the topic again the
other requirements these are we are
holding you to these maximum play length
to ten minutes single or multiplayer
game test your user interface well it
must use and play audio for the player
unless audio is absolutely not required
for your design if your design really
does not need audio then don't use audio
but if it has if it's a it's a web
browser experience there's probably
should be some way to use audio as a
method of getting feedback to the player
so it could be as very simple as a ding
when something happens
that's okay for this project what
matters to us is that you have a unified
aesthetic which we'll talk about on
Wednesday what exactly we mean by that
and then also we're asking to give
design thought to spectating users in
the final presentation you're going to
be presenting the games on the projector
people going to be watching the games
being played they should be able to
understand how the game has worked just
by watching it maybe they might need to
watch it one or two times to figure it
out but they should be able to figure
out what are the things that are going
on in the game and how are those how all
those interactions happening so your
deliverables that was from up till now
so on Wednesday turn into stellar a high
level design doc or back to box copy the
same form we've been using on previously
some kind of vision statement that says
at this point these are what we think
this the the features are going to be if
at any point you make a significant
design change that says our feature list
is going to change our game is going to
look different update that document you
have up until the end of the semester to
do that and whatever you turn in
whatever that document is on the last
day of class should be what game you're
turning in so that the that document and
the game should have the same features
in there but we would like to see the
the vert the any changes that happen
between now and then we'd like to see
how those changes happen and why I'm so
reflect them in that on Monday turn in a
product backlog you're going to do a
two-minute presentation the core of your
game design idea and then we're going to
do a play test on the twenty-seventh we
are going to have at least one possibly
two of our clients in on that data to
play those games jano and Jared both of
them came in for the first day of class
they were not in class on when the when
the intro when when Pablo was on we are
asking for some kind of sprint task list
be submitted to stellar weekly what
exactly that is is completely up to you
we've given you a format that we like
we've given you a method that we know
works if you decide to change that
method let us know what you decided to
change it to and why but whatever you
have at every week I should be able to
go to stellar and see what tasks you
have to do
for the next week's worth of work we are
asking for product backlogs that's
actually a concrete please turn give us
a product backlog the format used for
the product backlog doesn't matter to us
for the feature list if it's a list of
user stories what matters is that all
the features that you think are going to
be in the game are listed all the
features that are done are listed is
done on and you've done some kind of
estimation on what size those features
are and then we're gonna have you do 22
minute presentations in class all these
should all these dates are in stellar in
the Stella Stella calendar so the next
to two minute presentations are also on
November's 12 and then November 26th any
questions so far about any of this stuff
all right so project is due on wednesday
december 10th on stellar turn in all of
your previous builds on your written
post mortems your design change logs
your updated document and this time
we're asking you for four focus test
reports there are in class play tests on
the twenty-seventh the fifth and the
24th two of those could be used for
focus test reports the other two must be
external know and then yeah we're going
to have on postmortem presentations so a
portion of presentations instead of five
minutes you could have 20 minutes we're
asking for a polished presentation of
the work that's been gatha's that went
into developing the project all the
iterations that you made within it so we
want to know about your design
iterations in this presentation we also
want to know those five what went right
what went wrong what was interesting I'm
in the project so that's about 10 to 15
minutes given on process right so and
and team management too for all of your
games someone who hasn't played the game
before will play the game live on stage
so that's basically a this is a one way
for us to see somebody who hasn't played
the game before try it out and see how
it works
it's a little bit of you and a little
bit of us will do the best we can so
we're asking guests to come in we're
hoping our clients are going to be in
we're hoping some of them might have
already seen your games before some of
them haven't if you have friends we
actually some suggest you bring in
friends to play to come in I'm in to
watch the presentations maybe not play
your game play somebody else's game but
will we open the final presentation to
the public we have a rehearsal on Monday
the eighth and we have the final on on
Wednesday the tenth so on monday the
eighth you don't need to do the play the
game part of the rehearsal but you do
need to do a full dress rehearsal of the
entire presentation and the reason why
we're doing that is um we're going to
give you feedback on that on what you
might have missed what you would like
you to see in the presentation and
you've got a couple days to apply that
feedback to your presentation to make it
better basically I think that's it yeah
that's all from the other day so any
questions about to post mortem
presentations previous years i'll send
out the link to previous year so you can
see what we what these on tend to be
like but we've recorded them in the past
so you can see what other people have
done and that will go to the
announcements page on stellar all right
um it's 150 take a 10-minute break come
back at two and work in your teams so
the rest of class today is pretty much
for you to figure out what is this
project are you working on who you're
going to be working with and things like
that so what we're going to do is the
typical brainstorming process we're not
going to guide it so much this time just
a quick reminder you want somebody who
is in charge of facilitating it which
means reminding everybody what is the
problem and also calling out people who
may have trouble getting the getting
their words in front of the group like
people who are trying to get into words
edgewise so basically moderating their
discussion and someone of course taking
notes we have our sheets of our giant
pads of paper in front you can use chalk
boards for the cholera team we suggest
splitting in half but
well that doesn't necessarily mean that
that your brainstorming team is
necessarily your game team what we are
thinking is that after brainstorming you
will better know whether your ideas can
be split into two projects or not right
given how many cards just appeared on
there we really really really
recommended you split into groups but
there may be a more organic way to split
that because your eye your ideas may
actually fall down on or more clearly
defined lines I don't understand you
already did some brainstorming up there
but think what would you do with a you
know half the size of of the team then
after that have the discussion about you
know which who is on which team by the
end of class today you should know
exactly who is on your team how to get
in touch with each other what your email
addresses are what your phone numbers
are or instant messaging handles or
whatever and make sure that that you
figured that that out let's see one
thing that I want to tack on to Rick's
presentation earlier about the
expectations for the post more than we
brought up the person who has not played
your game before coming up and actually
playing your game and I know some of you
might be worried about that do be aware
that however that well or badly that
person performs it no matter how how
much do you like the game or like
completely misunderstand what what your
games about that is going to be at best
one-point-five percent of your total
total semester grade that's not really
significant it's not going to really
swing anything so don't worry about it
but we are actually good using those
sessions to gauge usability right you
know to what extent have you actually
designed the game to sort of make your
game easy for people who've never seen
your game to get into it this is this
these are the things that we want you to
be iterating on these are the things
that we want you to be catching for and
without having like a real life
high-stakes there is going to be a
person who hasn't played your game in
front playing your game you know you may
not take it so seriously so we want you
to be taking usability really really
seriously that's why Rick said the scope
of the game doesn't necessarily need to
be
all that different from the past but the
amount of polish the amount of time
amount of time that you've taught
through your UI you know it's what you
should be spending all your time on
finally we're going to go a little bit
more into games for learning and the in
the next couple of in the next week but
one thing that we want you to be
thinking about while you're
brainstorming is of course what is the
player doing now you're trying to teach
something to someone you're trying to
get them in a situation where they're
learning about a certain concept it is
ideal if the thing that you are trying
to teach them is actually the thing that
they are doing now there's a way that's
a couple of other ways actually um can
we break Constantine's that's like yep
sorry the jungles there to there are a
couple of other things that you probably
are already considering putting into
your game ah you know things like what
is the theme and I notice you know the
brainstorming for the cholera already
started talking about the exact story
line right so that's the theme of the
game actually match not just the topic
that you're trying to teach but also the
mechanics that you are designed that
you're designing for it you want to be
thinking and a couple of you have
already been asking about things like
who's going to be playing your game
what's a demographic I'll also be
thinking what situation are they likely
to be playing in are they likely to be
playing it on their own at home is that
what you want to design for and you can
specify this you can say that this is a
game that's meant to be played you know
by an individual person with an
individual computer on your own time or
this is meant to be played like in a
group with a where you know like the
snack game was played in a group right
in front of in front of everybody else
of course the things like you know that
that by the way falls into the frame it
the framing I idea what what is the
context in which someone's actually
going to be playing game to what extent
have they played games like what you are
describing you know if you are making
something like a hard core strategy game
to what extent do people need to be
familiar with strategy games in order to
be able to play a game or you know do
they just need to be familiar with
things like Facebook games for instance
or do you really want to make a game
that that doesn't assume much play
literacy at all you want to be looking
of course at the data and that means all
of the material that we provided you as
well as any information that you're
looking at in in Google searches or
academic research or information that
you're getting from the domain experts
from either the human that humanitarian
response lab or all the climate or the
client the climate Center is it right
claimant yeah so make sure that you know
yeah we are representing that as fairly
as you can because this is a game you
know you do have liberties to at which
point you can sort of abstract out those
numbers you know maybe are not
mathematically very very precise because
you're trying to get a sudden feel of
the game and that of course goes into
the aesthetics part not just the
graphical aesthetics but the way how
your game feels if you're trying to
represent you know a really really tense
situation on the ground and the way how
your data model makes it resolve makes
it feel like your game is really
clinical and very very easy to deal with
the situation as long as you know as you
know the tried and true formula then
you're not accurately representing the
situation even though you might be
accurately using data so make sure that
you're balancing that aesthetic feel
together with the content you know
whatever real-world facts that you're
putting into your game because these
games are all really about real-world
things you might want to make sure that
your fiction and narrative is something
that's not too fantastical or at least
if it there is a fantasy element of it
it is the part that has leased to do
with the believability of the things
that you're trying to do communicate you
know you can say that there is a village
or a city that's dealing with a cholera
epidemic
something and that's not a real city
anywhere on the map of the world but you
can look at that city and imagine this
could be a real city somewhere in in the
world you could you know go as far and
say okay this is like a you know Dark
Ages or something like like that because
the disease has certainly been around
for a long time but you you know you
want to be able to keep reminding people
that this is a real thing you know if
you say that this is a science-fiction
thing where you're on a different planet
and it's a completely different kind of
bug that behaves exactly the same as
Colorado and us I'm trying to feel that
maybe the fiction that you're creating
video game is undercutting what you're
trying to get this game to do we just
actually teach people about something
real so jump in on the fiction narrative
so things to think about your games are
being played by specific culture people
with a specific cultural background
especially the cholera game will will
likely be played by I believe it was
it's Ghana so students who are in Ghana
so what kind of culture do they have
you're gonna have to research that and
figure that out for those games to
figure out what kinds of common
backgrounds might they have that you
could talk about for the heat waves game
that actually has more of a focus on Red
Cross volunteers and university students
you can specify we understand that
people who are playing this game are
likely going to be from from Europe and
they're likely going to have this kind
of background like when you're creating
your high level game design document
come up with what you think you're what
you imagine your target audience to be
so you have this some kind of cultural
background to go to to use and so that
you're not again you're choosing fiction
that is going to be supportive and
helpful and not fiction that might be
not known or might undermine the idea
one thing to keep in mind with Finn with
the fantastical studies have found that
some games that have when it comes to
pandemics and outbreaks using the zombie
fiction actually can work sometimes
there is something to be said about
using a common fiction that people know
that people can say all right I
understand I understand how zombie work
hossam be on panel epics work because
I've seen all these films about it
whereas if he just told me it was a
disease
might not have seen enough films that
had anything about how that how a
disease is actually I'm spread so really
think about what is your problem what
fictions might be useful what narratives
might be useful for you for the problem
is right you use fiction to keep the
topics relatable and you know if that
means drawing on things on public land
popular culture you know that's great
that's a tool in your hand don't use
fiction as a way to paper over design
problems which I've often seen you know
if you set this game in space then we
can sort of like skip over all reality
something like that when you're
brainstorming make sure you know what
you're brainstorming about are you
brainstorming mechanics so about what
people are going to be doing or you're
brainstorming you know what the fiction
is going to be I would say do a separate
brainstorming session for each one of
these things maybe you know just spend
ten ten minutes you don't have to bring
some every single thing that we're
showing you here you could brainstorm
what is the aim and impact that you want
to achieve in this game how are you
going to all of you even on the same
page about what you want your game the
kind of change you want to see in a
world right and that's that's going to
be your purpose that's that that is
going what do you all understand what
this thing is a lot of it has been
defined for you but I'm not guaranteeing
that everybody on your team necessarily
shares the same idea so brainstorming
process might be able to get that out
and at some point of time within the
next couple of weeks you should have a
pretty good idea or you should have had
a chance to at least talk with your team
about every one of these elements this
is a research framework that's been put
together by one of our colleagues
Constantine mikich I think we can put a
link to it yeah almost worse the slides
in this particular arm slide stellar I
will get back to we might get back to
elements of this later in a week but
right now this is just basically
something to help guide your
brainstorming yeah aesthetics were
recovering on Wednesday on fiction we're
covering in a couple weeks finally one
reminder about brainstorming if you do
have if you're brainstorming session
runs more than ten ten
minutes you want to flip your
Secretary's around so that somebody else
is taking notes and let the person who's
been frantically writing things down
actually get their ideas into okay we're
not going to time that for you that's
going to be something for you and once
they've got their team's email video
game buzzes that's put your your vision
statement should have all your team your
team and all your member names in it and
that's due on stellar on the date that
it says so put all your names in
Division statement yeah rest of class is
yours